Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I am Rawkode,
your host. And today, we're gonna be taking
a look at behavior driven development, example mapping,
and a little bit of Gherkin potentially.
To do that today, I have a friend
of mine who is my go to in
all of these topics,
Kieran McNulty.
Hey, mate. How are you? Very kind.
I'm good. Thanks, though. Yeah.
Good. Good. Good. Yeah.
You are my go to. I think I
definitely send you far too many messages going
to help me, please. I have no idea
what I'm doing. So I'm glad that we
can do this in a way that we
can share some of that knowledge with other
people.
And
hopefully, using a project, but it's something I'm
actually really working on as we can show
them how this applies to, like, a real
domain and and and hopefully break it down
a little bit. Yeah. Great. I'm sure I
send you an equal amount of Docker and
Linux questions.
Yeah. Maybe our friendship's a little bit too
transactional. We'll see.
So,
like,
we should probably start then, I guess.
I mean, am I right in saying that
we're gonna use example mapping to understand what
I'm trying to build with a little bit.
Does that immediately go to Gurkin and scenarios?
How did all these bets go together? And
in fact,
back up. What's behavior driven development? Have you
got like a a thirty second pitch?
Sure.
BDD
is
one of the one of the characteristic things
about the BDD community is that isn't really
strictly defined.
A bit like kind of a bit like
DDD in that way, in that there's lots
of different ways of doing things. What they
have in common is a a kind of
approach a set of practices
to be used in
agile
type environments
that encourage fast feedback loops.
And BDD emphasize definition is good.
BDD
emphasizes talking about behavior
using examples,
and that leads to many things. It comes
from the TDD tradition
where you write a test first. That that
that's the kind of genesis of BDD.
Dan North was trying to teach people to
do this.
And
there's a kind of stumbling block when you
tell people to write tests first, isn't there?
Because
it doesn't make sense.
Right? When you go to school, you have
the test at the end.
You learn the you do the thing, and
then you then you get tested.
So Dan,
who I think was into things like NLP
and that kind of stuff,
decided to to to not use the word
test and instead
talk about
describe the behavior
first
and then implement it. So you in BDD
terms, you sort of think about those things
as specifications
or,
you know,
descriptions of what the system's going to do,
and then you implement it.
And then you somehow automate a test against
that description. So it's it's the same TDD
cycle, but you're sort of thinking about it
a bit different. And that was, you know,
twenty years ago.
Yeah. No. Twelve years ago.
Yeah. I I I'm not sure about like
this. You want me to know what I'm
writing before I write it? I mean, that
sounds
blasphemous.
You need to think about the thing.
Oh, no. What I mean is like, maybe
maybe it's just me and being an absolute
caboy of a developer. But generally, I just
hack at the code until I think it
does what I wanted to do and then
trying to look back at it. And I
I know that's a wrong approach. And I've
tried to get into TDD many many times.
Right. Well, I appreciate the design improvements my
code has when I do TDD.
There's there's still a,
like, a wall you have to get over
to really Yeah. Ingrain that approach on you.
And I I don't feel that I'm there
yet, but I do I am I am
getting better.
No. That's that's very
very true. And there's certainly a good argument
that a TDD approach isn't
a good fit for all problems.
If I've got absolutely no idea how I'm
gonna do something,
it's hard for me to write tests.
So another element of diagnostic BDD definition is
that it's sort of multilevel.
I can't remember the exact phrasing,
but it it can be applied at different
levels. So it it may be
just to give an example, it might be
I'm gonna write a script that's gonna recognize
images in
images of faces in photos.
And imagine I'm the first person who's ever
thought of that. You can't just rent time
to do that on some cloud service.
What test can I write? If
I don't know how I'm gonna do that
yet, if it's a sort of r and
d thing, I can't write a test
easily at a low level.
I can write a test at a higher
level,
which is, you know, if we get all
these photos, you'll know who's in them.
But a lot of the work I'm doing
underneath that level
won't be driven by TDD.
Right.
Just because
I'm just hacking stuff together.
So I find that a lot in those
very sort of unknown areas. I I don't
do TDD particularly.
I'll hack something together.
If that's good enough,
I won't worry about things.
But if that's something quite important, once I've
hacked it together and I've kind of got
a mental model of it, I maybe will
write a clean version that I do do
TDD. Because I kind of know what the
bits are gonna be and how they'll fit
together.
Oh, yeah. Definitely.
So something that BDD
has has grown to to
talk about a lot is acceptance testing.
So
when I'm talking to someone
at business level,
or maybe I and the team, we're having
to talk about what we're gonna build this
sprint, you know,
build next.
You can apply a BGD approach where you
think what what
what's it gonna look like when it's finished?
That kind of
feature level
acceptance test or acceptance criteria setting.
That's a nice
level to talk about because
you you can have that conversation at a
level that the business is actually involved in.
So it helps bridge some of that communication
gap.
You know, before we build it, can we
talk about what we're gonna build? Isn't that
controversial a conversation topic?
And you can do it in a way
where
the technical people will then figure out the
technical implementations
after.
So you can have a sort of, like,
business level
conversation, and that's that's tends to be where
people use BDD practices like the ones we're
gonna talk about today.
Yeah. And in fact, when we were talking
about potentially doing this session, one of the
things we said was,
so the thing I'm trying to build, I
want to be open source and I wanna
be able to tell people what it does
and then a a way that kinda reveals
the details of how it works. But, you
know, I didn't really know that myself either
and what we've decided was that this process
would be a way for me to kind
of submit my own knowledge, what I wanted
to do and how it works, and then
shoot up with other people and, you know,
we kinda get benefits without even necessarily gonna
straighten to the testing aspect of it. Just
that language and the examples tell people, hey,
this is what it does. This is how
it works. And, you know, that might affect
your use case. Yeah. And I, you know,
you know, I work with different teams trying
to do this. And I think the situation
you're in is something similar to a lot
of teams I work with where
they've
started with the testing.
Right? Yeah. And then but what what maybe
some of people in the audience don't know
how
Gherkin looks, but one of one of the
sets of tools that people use for BDD
is Cucumber. Others are available.
And one of the things you do is
you write down the steps of each test
in English.
Other languages are available.
And
why bother?
It's it's because that's then gonna get used
for something.
But if you're starting with the test and
then you're just then you're going back and
sort of saying, well, how will I you
think of the test and you say, how
am gonna write that in English?
It it it's kind of backwards, and it's
harder. It's much harder to do.
So the reason I suggested example mapping, which
I often do with these themes,
is, like, let's
do it top down. Let's start with your
understanding of what it's gonna do and then
drive out
examples.
Yep. And then some some of them will
be acceptance tests.
Because otherwise, you're sort of imagining
what the conversation we had before would have
sounded like if we'd had it.
Alright. So
should we well, first, we'll do a couple
of the comments. So
Mark Taylor, looking forward to this. Yep. Me
too. Glad you are. And common friend of
ours, James. Hey, man. How's it going?
Also, because I've been on PTO time off
for a week, I've forgotten how to stream
and actually do my job. So what I'll
also say is I wanna say thank you
to Equinix Medal. I'll put a code on
the bottom of the screen there. If you
wanna check out Equinix Medal, there's a $50
coupon.
Tell your bits. Right. So the domain that
we're working on today,
let me set a little bit of background
on this. I
do a lot of get ups. And if
you're not familiar with the term get ups,
let me try and give you the thirty
second version of that too.
Get ops is a method of continuous delivery
where we declare
and that's a clarity of fashion what we
want to be running and our production environment
through
manifest. Like, I do a lot of Kubernetes.
So we generally use YAML manifest.
Controller lives inside of the Kubernetes cluster and
continually pulls that get repository and applies it
into the cluster so that no matter if
manual changes happen to the cluster, they get
blown away very, very quickly. That's the very
quick version of what get ups is trying
to do.
Now I started applying this to more models
now that aren't just Kubernetes.
And one of the things that I felt
internally in our team at Equinix Medal is,
like,
a static site generator that pulls from YAML
parses that renders a site.
I want that to be continuous as well.
Like, whenever someone pushes a change to the
YAML
documents inside the get repository, I actually wanted
to serve that over an API GraphQL as
a database.
Yeah. I can see that weird look in
your face, but it's actually a really nice
approach. In fact, it's strange that James is
on this because he's written a YAML database
before. And this is not actually too different
except get as a database and I'm just
continually updating my models and memory and delivering
over an API. But it means I can
have a almost static or purely front end
generated site that knows all those Jamo documents
via the API.
The why, I can definitely cover more later,
maybe as examples
future episodes. But for today, what I wanted
to
well, sorry. So what I started doing a
month ago was extracting that get logic to
a library so other people can build and
roster on
get ops like operations.
So
the library we're using today is here.
I've not touched it in a month. A
month is when I reach out to you,
go and help. I have no idea what
I'm doing when it comes to BDD. So
I decided to keep this mostly
mostly for today's episode. So it's called get
synced. It's on getlab.com/Rawkode/getsynced.
Right now, it's very very trivial
and it
really just clones our repository.
And that's where that starts to get a
little bit complicated, is why I reached out
to you. Because
there are a whole bunch of rules and
semantics
that I really need to declare first. And
I wanted to do that viewing of with
feature files
so that I don't make a mess of
it. Because what happens if I run this
program, it codes the repository, it runs in
a loop, pulling all the changes, and someone
makes a manual changes.
Do I reset the repository
and then fetch again?
Do I throw an error?
What if there's a force rate on the
remote and I can no longer pull changes?
What's the procedure to rectify? And there's a
whole bunch of these
I mean, we all work with GET. We
know it's painful when something unexpected happens.
And I need to be able to codify
that now and these feature files so that
when other people
want to use this library, they can go,
what happens if someone forcefully writes to the
remote and then it's out of sync? Like,
what are what are the rules? And Yeah.
I want us to use example mapping to
try and document that. That make sense? Do
you have any tests at the moment?
Yes.
There are.
So in Rust, I have checked that it
can clone if there's nothing there,
which is the simplest test I could get.
And then oh, wait. That's the clone repository.
Oh, yeah. And this one is that check
to see if a clone exists, but we
don't I don't have any test to confirm
the logic of what happens when it does
exist and it tries to clone. So I
can check the the check that there's a
get repository where I want it to be,
and I can check that I can clone
if it doesn't.
And then that start to write a feature
file
here
and got really really lost. You can see
my sex laser gherkin before my brain exploded.
And it was really just trying to me
trying to take that test I'd already written
and write in the feature file, which you
just told me, yeah, don't do that. So
You can. I mean,
if it the use case you've got, which
is you're hoping people are gonna read it
in the future is a good reason to
do it. Right. So
retrofitting in that way, I'm I'm not a
% against it. It's just harder.
It's just the knowledge is harder. What what's
hard to do is
if you don't know who the intended audience
is, I think something you maybe struggle with
is just looking at it.
It's hard to know what level of detail
to go into. So when you're talking to
real
people involved in the project,
a mixture of business people, test people, dev
people,
you will
you'll talk about the project,
especially if you're having a quick conversation.
You'll talk about a project at a level
of abstraction
that the business people care about.
What I mean is there'll be a sort
of there'll be a depth
where they care how it works. Like, it's
really important that this thing happens. It's really
important that this thing happens.
And everything under it, they don't care about.
And that's really different for different groups of
people. Yeah.
What happens in, like, dysfunctional waterfall type situations
is that
you spend ages getting the business people to
agree to all the detail and writing it
all down, and there's a load of stuff
they really don't care about.
So some teams, it may be like, I
need to be able to do this action
somehow, and I don't care where in the
system I do it. I don't care what
the steps are. Like, I just I just
need that capability. And if I've got that
after you've got the feature, if I've got
that, it's a tick. Let's go.
Other people may really care. It's in the
specific
sequence of steps. There may be really important
business constraints to to put in there. So
what what I'm getting at is that the
the real conversation naturally finds that level and
capturing that in the scenarios is a nice
way of doing it.
Yeah. I think that depth is one of
the things I've definitely struggled with. I mean,
I've tried to adopt BDD multiple times over
the years. In fact, I think the first
time we met was when you were doing
BDD training at a company I worked for,
going back to what? It's like five, six
years now. So Maybe more. Yeah. Maybe more.
And, you know, maybe it's just my perception
of the BDD community or maybe it's the
journey I've taken is just not normal. But
I've seen examples where people say, oh, it
should be high level because it shouldn't get
into the implementation details. And then I've seen
examples where they actually do kinda get into
the implementation deal. Like, the depth seems to
change and now we're back up with another
what I see is a different version of
BDD where it's okay. You shouldn't cover implementation
details, but we do have examples which are
inputs and outputs.
Or I I mean, it's all very blurry
for me. It's not something I have a
a good understanding of. So let let let's
talk a little bit about example mapping. So
Cucumber's been around for ages. Cucumber is what
that Gherkin syntax comes from.
Matt Wynn wrote about example mapping
maybe
five or six years ago, and it's you
know, the
so the way Matt
talked about it,
they're they've been using different workshop formats to
try and come up with these scenarios and,
like, make it less about typing stuff into
an IDE,
more about talking about it first.
And, you know, there's still lots of ways
of doing it, but example mapping is the
one that kind of clicked for him. And
he blogged about it, and I started using
it. And
it's a good starting point. It's a really
great starting point of how are we gonna
have these conversations in our in our organization,
in our team.
You can you can tweak the format, you
know, for what works for you. Yeah. But
let we can sort of do a sort
of vanilla example mapping and and and see
how it goes. If you if you show
the mirror, I can sort of explain what
the components are. You shouldn't have sent me
at all your print, my joke. I was
gonna tell you to get your whiteboard out.
I do have loads of cookies.
You got loads. Of course you do. Of
course you've got stickies. Well, because I'm a
consultant. I went big on buying loads of
stationery and then I've been sitting in my
house for the last
so this is just a generic whiteboard, but
the the let's talk about what the primitives
are. So
you're in a different part of the board
to me.
I am
I'll I'll meet you in the middle. Hang
on.
Oh, there we are. Right. Here we go.
Zoom out a little bit.
So
we have
example, think who's in it?
People who know people who can make decisions
about business stuff.
So like a product owner type, BAs.
People are gonna build it because it's important
they understand it.
And if you're not, you know, if you're
not in the conversation and you just have
the notes from the conversation afterwards, you're not
you don't have as much, like,
implicit
background knowledge.
So is this supposed to be a Meagles
thing or is this different?
Yeah. And the people who are gonna test
it. Alright. Okay.
And the point is to early on align
the expectations of all of those people about
what it's gonna do.
So
it's called a feature. Right? So what's
I'll just do a I'll just let's do
the format first.
You put a sticky on the wall and
you say, right. This is the feature we're
talking about.
Yep.
Just to give it some sort of scope.
You may sometimes people talk about multiple features
at the same time.
I found this kind of conversation, it's best
to just do it in twenty minutes and
talk about one thing
and do that more often
rather than your afternoon of death when we
just stay in the meeting room
the whole time. So it's nice to do
a quick, you know,
twenty to thirty minutes.
And then you're gonna say
a feature is gonna give someone the ability
to do something, which is gonna make some
sort of change. Right? So they're gonna be
rules.
So you're gonna try and capture what the
rules are.
And
just by giving an example is a good
idea. So
a rule is something like
I've overused this example, but a rule is
something like
clothing is charged 20% VAT.
Okay.
So maybe that's not a rule of the
system. Maybe it's
items get charged at the rate for the
category of product they're in
to make it more future proof when the
VAT rate changes. Right?
So
the rules are really the things that are
gonna actually be implemented in the system somewhere
in code.
Okay.
But in general,
each rule is is either gonna be implemented
in code,
specifically in the software,
or is gonna be implemented offline through some
sort of policy.
Okay. So should we try and map my
domain to the first feature in the first
row or not? Let
just talk about the other two things. So
the the good thing about features the good
thing about rules is that's the thing we
really want to understand. What are the rules
of the system? What are the program what
algorithms are the programs gonna have to implement?
But then to make sure we understand
them
the wrong color.
We
give examples.
And when you're in example mapping, you're not
gonna write out a big old paragraph, but
you're gonna give an example of how that
rule would be applied.
And you'd think for most rules, you'd need
at least one example.
They're being implied in real life applied in
real life. And we scope we scope the
examples to the rule. Some would need more
than one example.
I'm sure you can think of a rule.
You know?
You get one one I've used in talks
is if you get free shipping more if
you buy more than the free shipping threshold,
you need an example where the free shipping
threshold is £50 and I spend £60, so
I don't pay any shipping.
And I need another example where
I go this. So so how do you
decide how many examples to give? We're not
worried about testing
yet.
Okay. We're thinking how many if I was
talking to David about this,
how many
examples would I have to give him with
details in before he goes, okay. I get
it.
I understand. A lot. Yeah.
Ideally
ideally, you'd hear some examples coming back from
you.
Okay. And then I I go, yeah. That's
how it works. So
because the rules are so nebulous, they have
lots of possible inputs, lots of possible outputs.
It's really hard for us to tell if
we've both understood the rule.
If you've got an example that's got concrete
detail in,
we both run it through our heads.
We both run it through our understandings of
the rule. And if we come if we
both say yes, that's how it should work,
then it kind of tells us we've got
that synchronization.
Yeah. Yep. Okay. And the other thing that's
important, especially in a big group, is we
also capture
questions.
So
a good even with the two of us,
this this is more applicable in a big
group. But often you'll have a question and
then you'll think, I'll ask about that in
a minute and then you forget. So it's
good to be in the practice of
writing down your question, especially when people start
doing it. I like them to only be
able to ask questions that they've written down,
which is a bit of a training wheels
thing, but it gets you into the practice
because
if there's five of us and three people
are talking, the other two can be writing
down the questions that are coming up, you
know, and buffering them up fully. So
that's it.
Let's talk about your feature. What's your feature?
Or you can start with the rules if
you want. No. No. No. No. So let
me I wanna because
thing just just to look
When we say what is a feature. Right?
I mean, I can tell you
the feature of the whole as an application
as a whole, right, is to continuously
fetch
and update a GET repository locally,
publish and changes as they happen. Now that's
quite large. So I'm assuming the feature level
has to be a little bit deeper than
that. So I'm thinking, okay. Does that mean
that our first feature is
it can clone a GET repository?
Is that the first feature? Or is that
too too low?
I have no idea.
They're actually something that comes out of
maybe
I'll phrase it like cloning a Git repo.
Now
feature really is just a way for us
to bunch these things together. And the more
I've done example mapping,
the more I start to think of
features as a sort of logical grouping of
business rules that all need to be implemented
together
for business reasons.
Okay. So that chunk
of work.
So it's related to that user story thing.
Right? The feature is the thing you might
have in your sprint backlog
or on your Kanban board.
It's like, we'll do these bits together.
Okay. Okay.
And
So why is that for as small as
possible is a good practice?
So calling a GET repository as as a
feature in this example mapping context. Right?
Yeah. If it's something you would want to
do
on its own. Yeah. I think I mean,
well, it is how I started breaking the
code. The first part of code I wrote
was I want this to be able to
clone a repository. There are a couple of
rules, which I'll try and guess now then.
So the first rule is,
as the directory already exists,
don't clone it.
Okay. So
we
need to sort of figure out what level
we're at. So
is that like if it's already been cloned?
Okay. So there are a few different semantics
here, I guess. Right? So,
I mean, we could go through the code
maybe or I can just try and remember
it. But what happens is when we say,
okay, start get sync.
The first thing it does is says, okay,
am I configured to pillar repository? Let's assume
that is yes for now because I don't
think that's particularly interesting.
And then says, okay. Does the directory that
I wanna clone this to exist? If it
does exist, then checks that it's a git
repository. It checks that the remote match is
what we are expecting the remote to be.
So it will validate that the repository cloned
as a GET repository and as the GET
repository that we want to clone.
And those are the two checks that happened.
Alright. So there's an example where
directory
my projects
exists
but isn't a Git repo.
Correct.
What what happens?
Actually, it will print an error and exit.
It gets synced when you run periodically.
So you would embed get synced into your
own application, which would run every five seconds
and try to fetch updates for that repository.
Alright. Because This is a startup rule though.
So if if it can't,
if that directory already exists on startup and
as in a repos a GET repository, there
just won't start the reconciliation loop.
What happens if it is a GET repository?
It will then inspect the remotes and check
for one called origin, which matches the configuration.
So it's basically saying as that's the repository
I'm supposed to be monitoring.
So you won't clone it?
No. If that check passes, it will enter
the reconciliation loop. If it doesn't pass, it
will exit with an error.
So Are you regretting your decision to join
me on this stream now?
No. It always feels like this in the
news
because I'm having to to level up, but
I'm I'm just
helps me to just focus on typing things
in and just type in what I'm listening
to until I start to understand it. So
I'm gonna ask some questions. So
but but enter
reconciliation.
Yeah. Reconciliation a little bit, I think, is
another feature, but I'm unsure. We actually have
a comment from Bradley who says, so as
the feature just gets synced and not cloning
a repository.
I
don't know. I'll rely on Ketan.
So I would say that of all these
things we're talking about, the feature is the
thing that's most sort of arbitrary.
Send me the feature as first clone or
get repository, then we enter the second feature
which is the reconciliation loop. Would that be
two different features with two different sets of
rules?
I we say don't worry about it. Okay.
It's
just the way of bundling some rules together
that we're gonna talk about as one thing.
And, ideally,
it's a bundle of rules that I mean,
if you wanna go down that route.
It's nice to have a feature that is
adds a capability.
So it allows allows
some entity to do something they couldn't do
before or stops them doing something bad that
they could do before.
Okay. No. Can I can I throw some
questions at you then?
Yeah.
So, you know, assuming other people are watching
this because they wanna be able to do
their own example map. Right? I'm assuming they're
gonna have some of the same questions that
I've got. Now the one that's set at
the top of my head is,
should I bog myself down with what the
features are? Or is, you know, could I
just keep listing examples and then kind of
segment them later? Is that another approach for
doing this?
You should. So
that's a really good question. Sometimes
it's hard to
there's two types of people.
Some people
will come in
if you put a business person on the
spot and say, right, you have to write
the requirements for this IT project.
That I mean, don't do that.
But that's what most people do. Right? They
say, you have to submit a thing to
this person by Tuesday to get it on
the sprint and all that kind of nonsense.
Some of them will
think through very clearly what are the rules.
And often that's in a domain that's very
rule oriented, like maybe accounting or law.
So they'll be able to write down things
like
you know, if it's something that's really familiar
to them, they'll be able to write down.
You can't issue issue a credit note without
it being attached to an invoice that hasn't
previously been credit note. You know? Something like
that. Yeah.
When you're reading those and then put it
in a load of paragraphs in Jira or
something.
But when you're reading that, can sort of
pull out the rules.
And all you need to do then
is make sure you understand the rules by
giving examples of how that you then generate
some examples,
and you're just checking that you've understand you've
understood the rules that you spotted.
The other way around is
maybe it's in a quite complicated situation or
there's somebody who doesn't have a huge knowledge
of the domain either because it's new or
they're new to it.
They might say, I don't know what the
rules are, but but if you ask a
specific question, what should happen in this situation?
They'll be able to tell you.
Which is like the examples first way.
So we certainly can.
There's only two of us, so we're not
the conversation isn't as busy. But quite often,
if you hear an example, just write it
down and don't don't allocate it to anything.
And then later on, we'll figure out maybe
that example has
told us about some new rules. You know?
Alright. Okay. But the end but
the end state is we want the examples
to be scoped to rules. So sometimes
you'll have an example and you'll realize there's
five or six rules being applied,
and you'll have to kind of decompose it
a bit to make it clearer.
You'll have an example that's like the whole
the story of the entire system. Yep. And
you'll kinda want to split it up a
bit. So
let let's go back to what we're doing.
Okay? Yep.
I'm doing that question.
If the repository was already cloned, don't clone
it. So that makes sense. The directory exist,
but isn't a Git repo. Show an error
because you can't recover from that. Yep.
If it exists and it is a Git
repo, we'll do a thing called reconciliation
next.
Well, yeah, we've messed so we also had
a director
as a Git repo.
It's not the rate queue. It's not the
correct GET repository.
Okay.
That
should
error.
Right?
But it could be a GET repository, but
when we analyze the remote, really, oh, this
is actually
some other GET repository. At which point, we
can't do anything.
And what's the rule about whether it's the
right reconciliation
whether it's the right one? It has a
remote
So if we imagine that when I'm I'm
gonna add up
like, I I like my own color. So,
I mean, if we imagine that the way
I start this would be repo
as is
let's just say, github.com/rockcode/rockcode.
Right?
And that's gonna
clone to a directory called
my clone. Now if my clone
has a remote that hasn't github.com/rockode/rockode,
then I just have to enter and exit.
It doesn't have a remote.
Well, it will have a remote, but not
the remote we expect.
So if it has a remote with correct
URL?
Yeah. You can see. Yeah. I don't know
what URL could be incorrect or correct. Yeah.
And with a different rule. Yeah. So we
we talked about didn't we the the kind
of level of abstraction.
Something that
is maybe important to talk about is that
different rules happen at different levels of abstraction.
And
it's important to capture all the rules you've
got, but some of them might not be
ones that the business people care about.
So
this is one where
a sort of
you could you could sort of say that
this this rule that I'm wobbling
about what makes it a correct remote
is a sort of
sub rule of how reconciliation loop is gonna
work.
Does that make sense?
Well, we wouldn't enter the reconciliation loop if
the remote was incorrect.
So those are the two checks that happen
on startup. First, as a a directory with
a Git repository and as the remote correct.
And then
we enter the reconciliation loop, has all of
its own rules.
So is that example in the right place?
Would you see that as part of the
Oh, no. I just stole that card.
Okay. So
I alright. Okay. So we're we're putting these
under okay. Yeah. That's my bad. Right? So
that example should have been under the other
rule. So so this thing about this this
rule about what makes it a correct
remote. So we've got this concept of it's
not the correct repo.
Ah. And
we're going into
what may we could go into from your
little sticky there. We could go into what
makes it correct repo
and whether to go in whether to dive
into that in example mapping is something where
you sort of read the rule, read the
room.
So is that something only the devs are
interested in?
Yeah. I think
so I'm trying to understand what you said
there. I think there's something really important there
that hasn't been exposed yet. You're completely right
about it. It's that I have this knowledge
in my head that says, it is not
the correct git repository under this circumstance. And
the circumstance is the code is hard coded
to check for an origin a remote called
origin.
And maybe that needs to be explicitly
stuck in somewhere.
But So It's it's like, do you want
that to be the the reason you're writing
these scenarios is to communicate with future people
using the library. So do you want to
be explicit in the Gherkin?
Well, yeah. I think it should be because
if people want to use an existing remote
that I don't that hasn't provided or hasn't
cloned by the library, then they have to
understand there's a rule that says
that is possible if your if your remote
is called origin.
Yes. We could go out some examples quickly.
Right?
And I'm just gonna do notes. So when
because it's a workshop. We're just doing notes
that are gonna remind us later of what
we talked about. Okay.
You don't start writing out given when then
in this.
But you need enough detail that when you
look at that note later, you'll have a
good stab at writing out the detail, if
that makes sense. So,
oh, Dan North has this thing. It's like
the friends episode names.
Yep.
So it's like the one where
has origin
but
wrong
URL.
That's enough to remind us later when we're
reading this. Right? It is.
Has no origin?
Yep.
Remote?
Yep. If we want someone might do that.
What else?
Has origin
pointing
to right
URL. So
it's okay.
Can you think of another edge case?
So the testers are good, actually.
No. I I I think the rule
is,
I mean, it's a relatively simple rule. It's
just good that we documented that, and it's
either right or wrong. And I think or
missing. Yeah. I think you've kind of documented
the three existential states of a remote, so
I'll go with it.
So this has two strategies for finding more
examples. I'll I'll just talk about them here.
One is
context questions. So you look at an existing
this is when you've run out of ideas
and you wanna generate some more stuff.
So you look at the context and say,
is there any context where it
let's can you see when I click on
something? Yeah. Can. I can. Yeah. It makes
it kinda shadowed.
See that one?
The directory exists but isn't the Git repo.
Don't claim it in it. Error. So any
situation where
so the context question is, is there any
situation
where there could be a directory that isn't
the Git repo
and we don't error?
No.
Okay.
So so you can ask questions like that.
Right?
So this one,
is there any situation where it would have
the origin
and the correct URL, but we wouldn't
consider it the correct
remote.
No. And maybe this again. Is this something
that's in my head that we have to
get on a sticky somehow? Because the reason
that the program will error and exit if
it's not a get repository or as it
hasn't got the correct remote is that
this library is quite destructive
and that it I mean, the way that
it would proceed would be to remove that
directory or start pulling the ref log over
the top of it. And, like, you don't
I never wanna be in a situation where
anyone
not I I can't say lose these data,
but if someone made a manual commit to
that repository and then I command and revert
it and, you know, reset and force pull
or something like that, then I definitely put
them in a situation where it's gonna be
a lot more work to get that back.
So the the rule is always just and
my head has been, well, if it's not
what I expect, then I can't proceed safely.
Exit.
Yeah. Kinda where I am. Yeah. Okay. And
you should you should definitely capture that sort
of thing now because we're trying to do
this in a cheap way. I know we're
we're talking through it because it's a stream,
but
we're just capturing what it's gonna do now.
Or if you're doing this at the start
of your sprint,
we're just gonna capture what we're gonna do
next. Yeah. Okay. It's gonna get committed to
the code base maybe as feature files, but
they're
editable.
So if it changes if
we change what it does, and actually we
have some way of recovering from
multiple directories, we'll change we'll change the features
then when we get to it. Yeah. I
mean, someone could come along at some point,
I guess, and add strict mode to this,
which just says, well, I I don't care
what's on desk. This is what we need
in this location, and we're always gonna blow
it away and make sure it's always the
get remote and no local changes. Like, that
could be a valuable feature eventually.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's maybe a difference between
the things that live in Jira,
user stories or feature requests. Right?
Or or other ticketing systems.
And the thing that lives in your code
base in the feature file. Because one is
like a change
a set of changes, and the thing in
your version control is like, this is actually
what it does right now.
You can read this to find out what
it does right now because we're automating tests
off it. So here's here's a truth about
the system.
If you're looking at,
know,
looking through old Jira tickets, you can often
find contradictory things and you have to work
out which was the label which one was
latest because that was the one that got
well, things get changed over time.
Well, I can contradict myself in a way
because, like and like I said at the
start, but I'm actually extracting
internal code, private code that we have within
our organization that I wrote to do this
job and I wanna make it a reusable
library for others.
The one we use internally runs in that
strict mode. It it will do a reset
and a clean on that directory before it
does every reconciliation.
But that's something that I'm personally willing for
it to do, not something I'm willing to
Yeah. Make you know, release open source at
least in the first version. So Yeah. You
don't want liability.
Exactly.
Right. So what else happens? So we're talking
about cloning. What else happens in cloning? So
this is other strategy.
So we talked about context questions. Is there
a context
where this
examples have an action and an outcome?
Mhmm. Is there is there a different context
where that action wouldn't cause the outcome? That's
the context question.
And the outcome questioning is her other sort
of line of a of a approach that
she talks about in a blog.
As well as that happening, what else happens?
So
as well as erroring in these different cases,
is there anything is there anything else that
happens?
Like, is there a log or is there
when exiting, is it
when we say error, maybe we should tighten
up. When when it says error, does that
mean exit?
Yes. So we print the standard error
saying directory exists, but as a GET repository
or directory exists as a get repository, but
as an incorrect remote, and then we exit
we exit with a non zero code.
I don't know how much of that we
capture in our example.
So
I think that the audience.
I mean, this is I guess, this is
another thing that's tricky for me is that,
Jen, you know, I can
I can understand the level users of a
blog want to interact with it? This is
a very developer centric library. So I guess,
going into implementation
details
has the right level of abstraction
maybe because developers want to know, alright. Does
x is zero? Does x are not zero?
Like, maybe that is valuable information.
Yeah. Writing
for the unknown audience is always harder.
If you were if you had a group
of developers who were gonna be using the
library
and we're and we're they're in this session
with us, we'd naturally find that level of
detail because you you can tell.
You can tell when you've gone too deep
because no one cares about it.
And
and the the trick,
if you're facilitating this kind of session, is
to recognize that's happened and say, well, let's
talk about that when we're building it and
you can write some unit tests, but we
don't need to have that in the in
the example map.
It's not part of it's not part of
the
I think the thing is you don't have
anyone who's giving you exceptions criteria. Right? There's
no one who's it's you're doing both roles.
Oh, yeah. I mean, I have some internal
voices that I try and listen to. You
know, they've all got different ideas for the
features. I'll try not to pluralize that again,
but, you know
yeah.
I I this is something that, again, I
built internally, and I'm just trying to extract.
So there's you're right. There's no there's no
users. There's no audience yet. I'm making a
lot of assumptions.
But if you do have that kind of
internal customer, internal stakeholder,
product owner type person,
you can tell when you got to the
point where they're like, yeah. I don't care
about that. Whatever you whatever you think.
Right? And that's the level you sort of
cut off at.
Because
why because? Because it gives you a lot
more freedom
of
decision making as you build it.
If
if right. Just as an example,
this this first
rule
Yep.
Doesn't say anything about exiting or errors.
So
if we're in the conversation and I and
I've got, like, some if if this is
something we're gonna sell, right, and we need
to get someone to approve it,
and we start you and me, the dev,
start talking about, like, alright. So should it
exit with a non zero exit code?
How much detail should we display the message?
You would tell
someone would say, I don't care.
All I care about is that it doesn't
clone the repository. And that gives you a
really useful heuristic that we're not gonna need
to capture all that stuff. That's something we
can talk about when we're building it.
And I can decide whether to implement that.
And, you know, with my selfish developer hat
on, if I run out of time,
I can do a really basic version of
it. And if I've got loads of time,
I can have a really amazing thing where
it, like, outputs it in a format that's
got nice colors and, you know. Yeah. So
I I get a lot more flexibility
about
how it's implemented and actually in an agile
context that makes it a lot easier to
fit things into sprints.
Because if you're running out of time, you
do it. You know what the rule is
for it to be acceptable to the business.
So you can cut corners or you can
do a really great job if you think
there's extra value to be had there for
the for the users.
You can do it even better than we
talked about.
But if you if you try and do
it all in the conversation and you try
and get all the detail, you're kind of
locked into one specific implementation.
Now this isn't a
UI led project,
but
some stakeholders won't care what the page looks
like,
or they won't k they won't care what
the interface looks like in the admin area
as long as it does the thing they
want. They they might trust the developers to
do it.
Other teams, they might want to see a
wireframe.
Okay. Again, you're discovering the level of detail
in UX to go into.
I I try and stay away from UX
stuff here because text isn't a good
medium for doing user interface
stuff. So
example mapping you can capture all the business
detail and then maybe say, okay, we have
to do some wireframes.
Okay. What what
so
I'm gonna get stint and it's gonna clone
the repo and we've got these rules about
whether it'll whether it'll clone the repo or
not.
Yes.
Yes. We do. What else?
So assuming
that we pass the rules
at that stage, we then enter the reconciliation
where there are some more rules.
Yeah. It's it's near the same.
So do you wanna call it a different
feature?
I think reconciliation has a different feature. Yeah.
I think there are two different stages of,
like
if if this was a state machine, that'd
the first stage where there's which is get
prepare for reconciliation,
and then there's reconciliation.
So I think it's probably a new feature.
So we've got our first feature, which is
clone the repository, and now we're in the
reconciliation loop feature. So I guess we can
just change this to yellow.
So did we have an exact yeah. Go
for it. If we had an do we
have an example that's
we skip in in the initial clone?
Have we got one more it's there and
it's got the right thing, so we just
carry on.
No. We don't.
So we do nothing and do reconciliation.
Now with that reference, the other row and
just the Yeah. Directory as correct repo,
so that means we can
move, continue.
Yeah. Repay is already closed, so they don't
need to clone.
Okay.
Repay is already cloned
on disk,
so we don't need to clone.
Something
that we don't really get in example mapping
is a time series of
steps.
So you'd normally sort of have to overlay
something else on that.
You can use user story mapping.
You can use event storming. Okay. You've got
a long running process that's a series of
steps. There's no sort of hour of time
in the in an example map. It's an
assumption that we we want to understand the
rules.
But if if it helps for you to
have those rules in a context of
time,
There are other formats.
There's also feature mapping,
John Smart's feature mapping, which is a bit
like example mapping, but it does have that
hour of time. So it's it's
kinda halfway between this and event storming.
Okay.
So this this is suitable where everyone's kind
of understands the steps. Imagine ecommerce. Right? Everyone
knows I put it in the basket and
then I check it out. Yep. And you
can talk about the things in isolation and
say, well, what are the rules of what
you can add to your basket?
So tell me about reconciliation.
Okay. So once we enter the reconciliation phase,
that just means that on a configured interval,
we are going to attempt to fetch all
updates to that repository.
And we can talk about which branch we're
looking at.
Yeah.
It's part of the configuration, which I kind
of omitted, I guess. So
the library expects you to pass in a
target, which is the branch or tag name,
the repository URL,
any authentication that's required.
I mean, we can talk about what that
config is. I don't know.
So does that affect
this thing about the being a quick repo?
No. Because the remotes
are would be configured regardless of target.
Yeah. Okay. So as long as the origin's
there.
As long as the origin matches the URL
that we expect, then we will attempt to
fetch on the target from the configuration.
So branches is gonna be something we think
about
as part of reconciliation,
maybe.
It it will be for sure. Definitely. And
and authentication.
Because so far, like, the code
I guess, authentication is important for cloning. But
if we have a directory exists and the
remote is correct, so that we don't need
authentication at that stage. So that is the
reconciliation that we do. Maybe that needs to
be documented. I'm not sure. But maybe we
should tackle some of the reconciliation first and
then handle the
off. I don't know.
Yeah. I'm just putting I put that question
there so we don't forget. Yes. Sure. By
the way, it's perfectly fine to come out
of example mapping with some unresolved questions.
That's natural. Yeah. I guess for for today's
example, we can just assume that the environment
provides us an indication that we need, and
we can have both that one later for
sure.
Yeah. And just in life, you know, you
you you talk about it and there's a
question that we don't know the answer to,
we have to go and ask someone.
And
if you're in a situation where you're deciding
whether you whether you're ready to start work
on it, you can decide whether there's too
many questions or not.
If you saw me.
If you got something that's got loads of
red questions on, might say, let's not do
it today.
If you're doing like a scrum thing, you
might say it's not ready for sprint planning.
If there's just a couple of if there's
one question that seems minor,
you can sort of say, oh, okay. Well,
we trust you to answer that.
I guess that's just an exploratory thing and
to understanding the problem.
Yeah. It's very visual to see all those
red stickies and be like, oh, maybe we're
not ready to maybe we don't understand this
enough yet, I guess. Yeah. Actually, if you
zoom out a little bit,
you can use the fit to width thing.
What's the fit to width thing? What's that?
In the bottom right, in the menu, in
the map thing, the the sort of arrows
either side. Yeah. Yeah.
Fits the screen. You
can sort you you're right. You can sort
of see from the shape what's going on.
That first feature, what do you think
jumps out?
Think it's quite nice. It's easy to see
there are two sets of rules and multiple
examples per rule. I don't know if anything
jumps out at me. Yeah. I think maybe
too many examples. It looks it makes me
think that that
rule could be decomposed into more than one
rule
just from the shape.
Okay.
So we could
let's not do it now, but we could
split it into a rule about the directory.
Doesn't clone if the directory's
not a git directory.
And we could have separate rule that was
like it doesn't also, another rule is
it doesn't clone if there's a directory that's
a git repo that doesn't have the right
remote. You know, we could split in this
into those two, and maybe that would be
clearer for a reader. That's the only reason
for splitting it.
Okay.
That's not the only reason for splitting it.
The other reason for splitting it then is
if you've identified these two rules and you're
in some kind of, like, prioritization
backlog
scrum situation,
I. You haven't done the work already like
you have,
you you sometimes say,
actually, that thing where the directory exists and
it's not a git repo doesn't happen very
much, so we can build that later.
And then we can if you the rules
tend to be the things that people care
about being delivered in batches.
Yeah. And this kind of vertical column thing
is really useful for either deferring work or
splitting things down.
Okay. That makes sense.
You know, what would happen if we didn't
implement that rule about error with a nice
message? Well, it'll just crash because it tries
to do a clone and there's the thing
already and git will do an error and
it'll be an ugly error message.
That's fine.
We'll we'll do the bit that catches that
and, like, pre checks and does a nice
error message as part of sprint four
instead of sprint two.
So, yeah, let's go back to talking about
reconciliation.
So it fetch fetched all the updates to
the repo and configured into it. What's the
happy version of that?
The happy version
is that there are no local modifications,
and it can do a fast forward pull
or a fast forward fetch and merge, I
guess,
into the directory and publish the changes.
Probably should I mean, that that's a happy
path. It should be 90
plus percent of
every run this does. Right? You know, people
are pro I would hope people using this
library and especially myself as a user of
the library. I'm running it in an in
an environment that wouldn't accept local modifications anyway.
So, you know So I'm gonna split this
actually. Feels like there's two things we're talking
about.
Fetches
happen on
configured
interval.
Because it sounds like there's a concept there
called a fetch.
There is. Yes.
But where is it configured?
How is it configured?
Via TOML or or command line argument.
Okay. So configured.
And what happens? It's just it's just running
and fetching like a daemon.
Yeah. So, I mean,
I I tried not to mention this so
far, but I keep completing my examples here.
As a getSync gets exposed as a library
and then a binary. So, you know, there's
those two different modalities. But I'm gonna try
and con try and stick to using it
as a library and forget. Because if we
get the library right, the, the CLIs,
the binary is fine.
So you you when you initialize the library
sorry?
So that's very common. Right? Most
software is a stack of things.
And
if you write if you write the examples
express the examples and the rules in the
right way,
you they apply to both situations. So if
we can phrase them
if for a website, if you
pretend that some people are on mobile and
some people are on the web and some
people are talking to it through Alexa, you
can see you can get a point where
you're phrasing it in a way where the
business details there,
the detail that's relevant to the rule is
there,
but
all other stuff isn't. Yeah. So if we
just say configured
with an interval of five seconds, then that
just means every five seconds, the reconciliation loop
is gonna run.
It's gonna fetch the remote
and try to do a fast forward merge
with the changes.
I I guess the simplest example actually would
be it runs and the remote says there
are no more updates.
So it doesn't do anything. That's it. Let's
just talk about configured fetches as one thing.
Right?
Yeah.
And then it fetches all updates to the
repo.
What's the example you just gave? No remote,
no local
or remote
pods.
Okay. Yeah.
Nothing happens.
So this is when a fetch happens. Right?
Correct.
So if there's no local mods, it does
a fast forward
Well, after no local mods, it will attempt
to fetch. So, I mean, if there are
local mods, it won't even attempt a fetch.
What will it do?
It will return an error and the reconciliation
that will exit
because we don't want to blow away people's
local changes.
Okay. So I think that sounds like a
new rule. Right?
Exit yeah.
Exit the loop if
and the the the number of examples you're
giving is a good sort of guide to
that.
Okay.
So you So after our local modifications, then
we just say, You've you've done something we
don't expect. We're not gonna blow away, so,
you know, good luck. Go fix it.
And it's up to the user to go
and either commit or revert those changes.
And the the thing we're talking about in
terms of prioritization, right, you could decide not
to do that yet.
Yeah. Correct. We'll write it in the manual.
Don't do that.
And that would get on the fine behavior
if they've made some local mods.
Yep. So, you know and the way you
sort of do that is you
you'd sort of say, well, okay. This is
a different feature.
We're not building out this sprint. We'll call
it
yeah. You put another yellow sticky there and
say,
we'll call this
local module function feature, and we'll have a
separate Jira ticket for it and, you know,
all that jazz.
Okay. If you if you do all that
stuff
with a different pull request.
Yes.
So you could implement the fetches happening on
a configured interval. Right? You could just
you're implementing it, you can just say, well,
I'm gonna do this configuration thing and I'll
just make sure it calls some function in
five seconds if that's what's in the config
file. Yep.
And I'll commit that and pull it push
it because it doesn't hurt anyone.
And then,
you know, then do the actual fetches.
So that's yeah. So no local remote mods.
Nothing happens.
No local mods does a fast forward pull.
Yep.
Are there any other is this is there
any situation where you'd have no local mods
and it would do a merge or something
else?
Yes.
So that there's I said fast forward very
explicitly because
there are, I guess, two other conditions.
It could be that when we fetch the
remote,
that history has been rewritten,
and we
are not actually able to do the fast
forward merge,
we would error in that case too.
At least for now. I mean, I think
there may be features in the future where
we try and handle that better.
But for now, get sync really because the
simplest path is just to expect a linear
history and get like, this is supposed to
be an automated system. We don't expect people
to rewrite the history,
at least initially.
And I guess that could be like the
branch was deleted.
It could be
someone did a rebase, someone modified a commit
message. It could be I mean, there are
many examples of what would break
fast forward
merge.
Right. So and you're not gonna club in
the local
if the remote's changed? Yeah. I want to
add her and say, hey. The history here
has changed. We expect you to go and
blow away that directory and we'll clone it
from scratch.
We may provide a flag that does that
automatically,
but, again, I'm trying to do this the
safest way first and then add on
overwrites.
Yeah.
That's a good example of, like, you might
do something different in future and you'll come
back and take this example out. Yeah. Exactly.
So what else? Are there any other situations?
Let me look at them.
So when there's no local remote mods, nothing
happen nothing at all happens?
Correct.
Nothing else happens?
Yep. It goes back to sleep till the
configured interval then whoops.
And we're always gonna try to do a
fast forward pull.
It will only accept the fast forward fetch
and merge. Yes. So
I that's a yeah. A pull would be
a fetch and merge. So
I mean, there are things that happen when
there are those changes. Maybe we need to
bring in those. I don't know if that's
a different feature or not. I'll trust your
judgment. But
say there are four commits that branch, I
guess that's unlikely depending on the interval. But
say there are four commits,
it will then work out the depths of
those commits, look for all the files that
have changed, and it send it publishes a
message that says, hey. These files have changed
to any number of subscribers.
Okay.
So does that sound like maybe I well,
I think what what
what I would tend to do is have
that as a rule here.
And if the feature's looking wide, I think
we'll are some of these things a different
thing? Okay.
So what what
pull reports.
So yeah.
Yeah. Pillar ports. I I mean, I don't
know if I'd use that vocabulary. I don't
know if that's important. But
It is important. What would you call it?
Go on. You type it.
I I thought I just got to watch.
Right. Okay. So
changes to
Rupo are published
on file level. So it's not patch level.
We only inform you that if fail has
changed, not
which lanes, not which blobs. None of that
is important.
The idea being that whoever signs up for
subscriptions can say, I want to be notified
of changes within this directory.
And that this is this is future work.
I'm not gonna get into too much. But,
you know, you can say as a consumer
of this library, here's my subscriber. He wants
to know all YAML files in the directory
change.
But the the first one is just, hey.
Here's all the files that changed.
So is that right? If I put four
commits to feed dot text, I get one
notification that feed dot text changed? Correct. Yes.
And if I put one commit
to feed dot text
I'll do YAML actually because if that's more
like your use case. It's good to match
these cases.
Yep.
Two notification.
I get one notification with both files or
I get
two notes That's
that's a good point. So right now, you
get one notification
that has
multiple objects in it. So it'd be a
list of files that changed.
Yeah. Yeah. So one notifications would What
so why have I put a filename in
there?
Just because it's The filename is what will
be listed in the in the change set.
Yeah. So as long as that's understandable to
everyone.
So if nothing's
pulled,
do you get a notification that nothing changed
or do you get no notification?
There would be no notification.
Nothing would happen. So,
you know, whether this is a different feature,
we've talked about it a few times already,
but it just depends on whether you feel
like you're gonna do it all in one
go, whether that's gonna be something you might
do separately.
Which is a sizing thing. It's that feature
scope. Right? If you're a team who are
trying to get everything down to a day,
maybe you'd use that as a nice scene
along which to split your feature.
I mean, I think I would. I mean,
I'm already thinking about this from a code
point of view. And I think, you know,
I really wanna make sure the reconciliation lip
is solid and tested. And that just means
I probably would have notifications or pops up
as a new feature afterwards,
but I'm happy with the reconciliation.
So, yeah, we to move over. And
even within the features,
I would tend to work on these rule
by rule sometimes as as a way of
organizing my workflow. So that's
probably enough to talk about for now as
an example of how to do it.
Sweet. How long is that? Four fifty minutes?
An hour and ten.
Yeah. But we chatted for a bit at
the start.
Oh, we did.
I thought you made it a total. Alright.
My energy is dropping.
Yours might be as well.
That and that's why I sort of say
half an hour. It would be better if
we talked about this first bit
one morning,
and then the next day over the lunch,
come back to it and say, you know,
what what else should happen.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So
and then then if if you've got a
couple more minutes, what I so I'll make
this board I'm saying that's enough.
I just make this public to the world?
So, yeah, I can. Okay. Cool. So
I'm gonna go and split that first
rule.
Okay. So in the show notes, I'll I'll
put a link to this board if anyone
wants to follow along at home.
I'm curious then before we finish up. It's
like,
you know, I I I wanna start getting
this library
moving forward. Right? And that's just been really
good. I've taken a lot of the knowledge
that I had in my head about how
I want it to work, and we've now
got that with rules.
What is my next step then as a
developer?
Do I start writing
scenarios and feature fails to map to these
features? Like, as as each one of these
yellow post its
one feature and then a rule as a
scenario? Is that a fair mapping of what
I what I do next?
Yeah.
And so
very specifically, these map to Gherkin syntax. And
what we could do
what time do you wanna finish? Half past?
Yeah. Roughly. Later?
That's flexible. Whatever you've got, mate.
So let's write some of it out as
Gherkin. I'm just editing the which is a
bad thing to do. Just
to separate
out that
big one
with the directory.
What what if refactoring is important.
So
did we have the happy version?
No. The on disk,
so clone the remote.
Correct. If it actually exists and isn't a
git
clone,
error.
Not clone. Checkout.
Checkout.
If the directory is Git,
but it doesn't match the remote, don't clone.
And I think
I think all of these
are examples
of that rule. I think this is the
same rule.
Okay.
It's just the definition of what correct is.
So
Does that make sense? I'm gonna get rid
of that.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
So these are all explicitly
error error versions.
Yep.
It's often good to go run through at
the end of example mapping, do a bit
of this.
And it is a bit easier. It's a
bit easier in person
because people are willing to move stickies around.
And it it's easier
if you're in this kind of session and
there's loads of people familiar with it. I
think the first time you do it, end
up with one person being the sort of
owner of the board. I think I've done
that a bit today.
And he's the only one typing. So if
you can try and break that down a
bit if you're doing this in groups,
that could be productive. Know? While while Dave
and I were talking about the other stuff,
someone could have been coming back and
clarifying this to their own sort of satisfaction
and then calling you back. So
So
that's probably enough output. Which feature do you
want to quickly do in in
Gherkin?
Well, I feel like the initial clone feature
will be the
the simpler one. But
Are
you able to do some sort of split
screen with the
IDE?
Yeah. Sure.
Oh,
yeah. You're a Mac user now. I am.
You've joined us. Oh, I'm trying to be.
Alright. So there we go.
So delete that example.
Delete?
That's how it worked.
Undelete it. Let's look at it. It looks
like a rule to me.
Oh, no. Maybe not.
Maybe that's an example. What I wrote was
yeah. I I think I tried to encapsulate
everything in a single example as if I
was trying to write, like, one end to
end test, which it looks like was necessarily
the correct approach.
And then I that's as a rule,
I think that I got a little bit
confused. This is yeah. If there's nothing there,
then this is what I expect to happen,
and then I was gonna try and layer
on the the edge cases after that. So
try comment that well, we just start from
what we've mapped.
Feature?
So this would just match this. Right? So
initial
colon of
the repository.
Right?
So you're you're expanding on stuff because we
it's just scrappy notes from your conversation. Generally,
one or maybe two people would go away
and write it up.
And
who does that?
I like Matt Wynn's heuristic, which is whoever
learned the most.
So
what we're gonna do is we're gonna write
this down
and then we're gonna we're everyone who's in
the meetings here, but we then share it
back and say this is what this is
what we talked about.
And if you do that on short enough
time scale,
like day hours or days,
it's really easy for the people who were
in the conversation to read through it and
just go, yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Right? Yeah. Because it's it's already loaded
into their head. Okay. If write it all
down and then six months later,
show it to someone, they won't know what
any of it means
sometimes. Or they won't be able to tell
say, yes. That's what we talked about.
So it's important to have that feedback loop.
Whoever
feels like they learned the most, so maybe
that would be me,
would then write out the examples with more
detail, expanding on it a bit,
show it to the people who had the
more knowledge at the start. And if they
if they say, yep. That's right. It's that's
an important validation step that I understood it
because I was able to sort of talk
it back to you.
I do that with my daughter. If I
tell her if this is some important instruction,
I ask her to say it back to
me,
like, to make sure she went in.
So you've got feature.
There's you can now have what's called a
feature narrative. You can have, like, a paragraph
or more of stuff.
Right here? The parser just looks for the
word.
The next line. Yeah.
Anything that doesn't have the word
example
with a colon
is gonna be fine. The parser will just
seek to the next the next, you know,
keyword. So that's a good place to put
some.
So would you call if we wanted the
name,
it's it's like bootstrap get repository.
Like, maybe give it a
catch your name and then use a narrative
to actually explain what that means.
Yeah. When we first we need to check
blah blah blah blah blah. You can put
your
as a
so that
we need to be able to If
you want if you want if you've got
that, don't don't create it if you haven't
got it.
And you can put random other things that
people talked about, you know. This is for
Barry in the accounting.
It's just for some free text for the
that's gonna be useful to a reader. Right.
Okay. There's lots of places you can put
free text in a feature file, specifically because
we're expecting them to be read by people
as well as passed
by
robots.
So, like,
chart and street like that for now?
Yeah.
And now which cucumber are you using? Do
you know?
The new syntax stuff that we talked about
a few weeks ago when I was curious.
It works. Like, so
So Gherkin six was the first one that
added a new keyword for ages. Gherkin what?
Sorry?
Gherkin version six.
Uh-huh. Okay. Cucumber Cucumber six was the first
one that had a a Gherkin change for
a while.
So you can put rule in because we've
doing example mapping a lot. You can put
a rule. So what's the first rule?
Local
directory
doesn't exist.
Yeah. You can phrase it as a rule
though.
What what
you can put what you can put it
on the sticky, you know.
So repositories
are cool and if not already?
So we have in the blue. Right? Already
on disk. You you're improving it from the
workshop.
You're making it into sentences.
Oh, right. Sent. Okay.
You know, this is
potentially gonna be mapping on
to
some code.
Okay. Now this should I I put a
new lines or
it's all set on a line? Does that
matter?
All goes on the line. It's good incentive
to keep it short.
Okay. So I got a comment saying I
am difficult to understand stuff, you know. Yeah.
I I do have allergies and they're quite
bad today. Sorry about that. Plus I'm Scottish,
which means I'm not really natively speaking English
anyway, but I'll I'll try and improve.
So thanks.
I don't know if we can support some
Scots yet.
It might do. You can contribute translations
in the main Gherkin repository. So there's a
it's a little language thing you can put
at the top of the file and it
switches all the keywords into
something else.
So underneath the rule, you can have another
paragraph if you if it's a really complicated
rule and you want to sort of explain
the reasons behind it, but let's not bother.
And then you indent we've got one example,
haven't we? We do have an example. So
we would say
no local.
I keep trying to take this in pale
case. I I don't know why I have
this taxation with using pale case. I need
to try and get over that.
Because it's the happy path,
we could either
not give the example a title
because it seems a bit like the thing.
Or you don't have examples don't have to
be in a rule.
So sometimes for short feature, I'd have the
example just under the feature.
Under the example, we have these steps.
So given when then.
K. So, Gavin, I have no local directory.
When I
when I do the thing. I don't know.
When I sync the git?
When I do git? When I sync the
git,
then
I
have a locally
cloned
version. I mean, I always really suck at
this given when that stuff. So That's okay.
So the the important thing up here. So
given I have get sync configured, so we're
we're not talking about configuration right now, and
our local directory does not exist. So I
have no local directory. Yep. When I sync
a get repository
yeah. When I sync
the
get repository,
then the repository is gone. Essentially, I think
my language server is probably better.
Yeah. Is that good? Yeah.
So the the
there are some things
we could talk about here. So how much
detail do you want to include? We could
include the URL
of
the Git repository.
And it really doesn't matter from in terms
of automation,
and it really doesn't matter in terms of
business
agreement.
It's purely, is it gonna add value for
the reader
to understand that that rule? That's the important
thing to
to to to do if you're using rules.
Does it help understand that rule?
Would a reasonable person
understand
that it's the same URL? It's the same
repository that's gonna be cloned.
So should we I mean, would we provide
a table here with example configurations?
Like, what the target directory like, we don't
see what the local directory is. Does that
mean that GET sync always clones to a
a hard coded location?
You know, should we
is it something that's passed in through a
configuration, which means we have to make it
very explicit in this example? Does that matter
yet?
Good questions.
It depends.
I knew you were gonna say that.
It's
about it's about the target audience. So would
a re if you think about who's gonna
be reading it,
are they gonna assume
that
the git repository I asked to be synced
is the one that's cloned to disk?
So what I have in my head is
we haven't in our example mapping spoken about
configuration.
Now maybe that the first version test I
released doesn't actually allow you to configure it,
and it probably has a hardcore location, and
then that's that's scenario doesn't care. And it
may be that I come back later and
add a new feature that allows them to
configure
how that that works. And then that those
features and those rules and those examples will
have something that says here's how it's configured
and that's how it works. I mean, this
is is that fair? Okay. Yeah. When you
when you're on a greenfields project, most of
the time you're writing new feature files.
As it grows,
you start to be editing the feature files
more often.
So you might come back and look at
this feature and say,
actually, there's some more there's another rule which
is we can
clone to a place that isn't the default
if it's configured.
Or there could be, like, you add extra
examples for if if a different location's given.
It could be doing it in a different
file. It's it's kind of optional.
That management is really
it's about how you think of these things
in inside the business.
Okay. So I don't think it matters then
unless this feature failed, that's rule in this
example because
we haven't explored the configuration
element yet. Right? So Yeah. Yeah. And I
think so so we could add in when
I sync the repository at
git sort of colon whatever.
Mhmm. Then git colon whatever is cloned to
disk.
But I don't think a reasonable reader would
expect anything different. Do you know what I
mean? Yeah. That's true. Yeah. Think anyone would
think you're gonna implement it, so I asked
to get sync some remote and that you
sync some different Git repo.
So I think that's enough that's maybe enough
detail, but it's definitely a judgment call for
for the author.
So that's so what's the next rule?
Well, we have a question if you wanna
tackle that Yeah. From James.
Is examples synonymous with scenario?
He's
always used scenario. Is there a case where
one would use scenario versus example?
Example is just more understandable to most people.
They're actually implemented as synonyms
in the
parser translation.
So implementing was quite easy. They just added
an ex in English, it can be scenario
or example.
It's exactly the same thing,
but just experience of talking talking to normal
people.
I I I was working with someone recently
who's got a sort of languages background, and
she was referring to them as scenario I.
Scenario I. Yeah. Which I think is good,
but
it sort of shows it's not really plain
language.
So they are the same thing.
Okay. Great. That's good to know. Give
me an example of how that would be
applied than it is to say,
what scenario you know,
think scenario is more for people into tabletop
war games like I used to be.
Yeah. I think example makes more more sense
to me. But rule feature rules and examples,
I think they apply better to me than
what the previous syntax did. So. Yeah. And
rule has been retrofitted in because it was
so useful to talk about, you know, talking
about these things in the context of a
business rule is really useful.
Okay.
Agreed.
I've heard of a company a big company
in The US who are using this as
a way of finding out what their business
rules are.
So they they kinda grip their feature files
and they discover which business rules are implemented
in their system.
Interesting.
Alright.
So
we have our first rule documented,
our first example
provided. I'm assuming
I mean,
again, developer head on here. Right? Would I
go through each of the example mappings, techies,
all the different rules, and put that into
a feature file? Or at this stage, would
you go and start writing a test for
your first rule and example? Or does that
does not matter? Am I just overthinking that?
At this stage, just after example mapping, I
would
write them all out, not worry too much
about it being gherkin syntax, and share them.
So if using a ticketing system, maybe you
put them in there,
maybe paste them into Slack,
and get a thumbs up.
I'd do that validation of the things we
covered in the workshop.
Then Okay. It's like then it's like, when
are you gonna work on this feature? It's
in your backlog and, you know Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Today, I'm gonna work on initial
clone. I would then
put that feature into the code base
as part of my commit.
Now you can use tagging.
So I'd probably copy paste it all out
of
wherever I got the feedback and get it
all into
get here. But then you can tag things
as excluded.
So all cucumbers have a sort of tagging
system. So
I would probably put how many examples have
we got? One, two, three, four three rules
and five examples. I've probably dumped them all
onto disk is the first thing I did.
And then
maybe I'd put an at
I don't know. Not implemented yet
on the ones I haven't done yet.
Except everything except the first one I'm gonna
tackle. And then when I run Cucumber, I'd
run it with
yeah. Something like that. You can run it
with don't run the ones with that aren't
implemented yet.
Get one of the scenarios passing.
So the tag can apply on the example
or on the rule or on the feature,
if that makes sense.
It does make sense. Yeah. I mean, I
think when I was you know, I've already
written
some crude testing
for my previous
one.
So
I think for now, what I'll do is
I will type up all of the example
mapping stuff into feature fails, not implement it,
and just push that to the repository
and then
continue from there.
Sunny?
I tend to do it as part of
the same PR.
You can do it as a different commit
if you want to, but
What do you mean? The test or or
the the admin? Because you told me to
commit all the feature fails to test first.
So in my head, I'm like, okay. I
should just go through the example map, write
all the feature fails with the rules and
examples that we have,
Push that up. You know, I don't have
a team. That's just an open source thing
that I'm working on. But, you know, in
theory, by being there on the GitLab repository,
other people can see. And I and then
I would go back and start to add
the actual test cases and the functionality at
the same time.
Right?
No?
Yeah. You can do that. I think I'm
I'm more used to sort of
inside a company, you'd be doing that
sharing and getting feedback
outside of Git.
I guess GitOps, you'd be doing it inside
Git. Right?
Right. I guess, you know, if anyone wants
to write some Rust code and find us
to be an interest, then even just by
me getting these feature files and pushing them
to Git, I can say to them, I'm
watching, hey. If you wanna learn Rust, this
might be a good opportunity for you to
come and write code that would help me.
So and Yeah. That's definitely
true. And
there are tools that sort help that. So
oh god. I can never remember the names
of them. So one
called
I really should know. So the Q can
have a tool that will connect to your
Git repo
and expose the feature files in a nice
explorable,
commentable,
editable
interface that's so friendly for people who don't
aren't really into Git.
And there are other similar tools. So so
there's definitely a sort of level of collaboration
that happens.
I I think for this particular domain, people
that are not interested in GET probably don't
care about this project.
But you're right for sure.
We also got another
sorry. I need to again. Yeah. Go for
it.
It'd be interesting to just look at maybe
some way of publishing the not implemented ones
in a specific location.
Yeah. Open an issue open an issue for
each one.
Yeah.
I should do that actually, shouldn't I?
We also got another comment from James, which
I just cut out your face while we're
at it.
But his favorite thing about Gurken is just
the documentation side of it and not so
much the testing. And, you know, I don't
know if I'm right or wrong,
you're back.
I don't know if I'm or wrong, but,
I mean, BDD, they always say it's not
about testing. Right? It's it's about the human
aspect of it rather than the automation side
of it.
Yeah. And depending when you're having these sort
of example mapping conversations,
you might discover a business rule
and then not implement it in software.
It might be something
the people using the admin system do.
Right? So
the rule is you can't mark an invoice
as paid if it is
more less than a thousand pounds without
more than a thousand pounds without approval from
supervisor. We might might uncover that in example
mapping.
And then when we're looking at the practicality
of when we're gonna build this stuff, we'll
just say, okay. We'll write that on a
email to everyone.
Don't approve an invoice.
Yeah. But maybe you want to document that
as part of your
your your your documented
features and tag it with, like, at offline
policy.
Just good to know what the rules are
sometimes. And then it gives you an an
opportunity in the future.
Maybe you can automate it.
Yeah. I I I think that's definitely the
the same vibe I had when I started
when I when I wanted to write the
feature files for this. We really just expose
the rules of what happens with the library
when you use it. I mean, the test,
yeah, that that would be useful. But really,
it was just about documenting, hey, if you
use this and the directory exists,
the best way to find that out, what
happens, or what the conditions are for it
to continue operating successfully is just to read
the feature files.
You know, this for me is very much
the documentation on how this slightly esoteric
library is gonna work
more than the tests. Otherwise, I do want
tests, but so
Yeah. So let's talk about tests. Right? So
just looking at this feature,
you could do that in three commits.
Right? You could you could implement cloning as
assuming the directory is never gonna be there.
Yep.
Write a test where the directory is not
there
and sort of implement that first rule
and, you know, call it a day. Go
home for the day. If you've got some
time, you can make the next one choose
one of the others. If the directory exists
but isn't a git checkout, you can add
a guard.
And then implement the third one, which involves
more git.
But as you're working through that, each each
business rule
yeah. We mentioned earlier each software project is
a stack of different layers.
And where you choose to text
really affects
how the architecture's gonna look because
the level you choose to validate something at,
you're sort of constraining
that the rule has to be implemented below
that in the stack if you wanna look
at it that way.
So you've got your sort of core. You've
got your user interface y stuff, which in
your case is a binary or it's library
calls.
Mhmm. And underneath, you've got infrastructure. You've got
Git,
which I guess you might have some interfaces
around,
you know, some abstractions around. Yeah. By
narrowing down
what part of the system you're
testing, you're actually testing the rule.
You you're constraining where the rule is.
So if I
let's take this first let's let's take the
if the directory exists thing.
If you choose to test that through the
CLI
and the way you would choose these different
testing strategies is you'd tag it.
So you'd have one set of Cucumber tests.
So one one set of Cucumber steps, like,
you've got that implement that are running the
CLI,
and they but then they're filtering on the
ones that are tagged at CLI or something
like that. Yep. And then you have another
Cucumber world, don't know what it's called in
the Rust version.
That's
different implementations. It's it's testing it by calling
the library
with a different tag.
And you run different sort of filter sets.
Right?
If you test it through the CLR
Just wanna check if I actually set it
up properly.
I'll come back to it. I'm sorry. I'm
go.
So this this rule, if the directory exists
and isn't a git checkout error,
where do we want that to be implemented?
If we if we test through the CLI,
it can be implemented in the CLI
command,
whatever it is. Yep. Or it can be
implemented in the library.
Or it can be implemented in git.
So it could be implemented by Git throwing
an error,
and we're just catching it later. So that
Yep. We don't know where the check is.
That might be fine
depending on the project. Like, as long as
it's in there somewhere, it's fine.
If you want to ensure
that it's in the library, then you should
automate that test at the library level.
Same scenario, but you automate it at that
library level and then you know it's not
implemented in the in the CLI.
If it's a web app, you know,
you check it at some by calling some
service, and then you know it's not implemented
in the controller or the template or the
JavaScript.
Maybe you want it in the JavaScript, so
you implement it in the JavaScript Cucumber
that doesn't have a real back end. Yeah.
But you're choosing for your test strategy where
you want the rule to be implemented
in future as well.
Now at the other end, you've got the
infrastructure.
So how do you stop things being implemented
with by a database trigger or stop things
being implemented by just Git? Already has that
behavior.
You have some abstraction and you would replace
Git with a fake in your tests. Right?
If if you want to constrain it to
just being implemented in that middle bit,
which is more of a decoupled architecture.
But but the testing strategy helps you design
the architecture.
I'm writing an abstract for a talk like
this now. It's good to
if you see what I mean. On
some projects, you might be super happy. You
test the whole stack, and I test it
by calling the binary. And as long as
it's in there, it's fine.
Your thing, because you want it to be
a library,
you should primarily be testing at the library
level
and then testing a subset at the CLI
just like a smoke test.
Yeah. That makes that definitely makes sense to
me for sure.
So why don't
And do you want it to be independent
of git?
No.
So you probably need git in there.
Unless there's speed problem.
Just
It's tied pretty heavily to lib git two.
I mean, obviously, we could say there's an
abstraction where it should be able to support
other version control systems. But I think with
the equity of get, it's just not something
at least in any
short and medium term goals of the project
for sure.
Okay. So in that case, you wouldn't bother
testing the fake git if git's fast enough.
If you find your tests are going really
slow because it's doing real git, you might
do it. But that kind of, like, architecture
test strategy,
you wouldn't deliberately replace Git.
And it means that your business rule about
the directory exists might be implemented by Git
by LibGit.
Yep.
I mean, the CLI Git does throw an
error if the thing already exists. So maybe
you can just catch that exception from LibGit
or catch that error.
And you don't care where where in that
stack it's implemented.
So so each of these things, just think
about what level to
to test that to to make sure the
rule's there. That's one of the key things
about rules is they're actually implemented somewhere.
Examples aren't implemented.
But rules have a kind of specific location
if they're if they're fine grained enough.
They're in a library or they're in a
service or they're in a UX UI component.
Okay.
So
let's let me see if I can recap
this then.
So we were using our example map and
technique, and I think let me see if
I can just stop splitting the screen actually.
Let
me go back to here.
And we managed to, I think, quite well,
go through a a large chunk of this
library. Right? You know, we've got various features
here. We're cloning our repository, called up this
trap, whatever I want, or maybe kept that
out slightly.
Snappier name as a phase.
We've got the rules here, and we've got
examples.
And just as our back and forward, as
we were going through that, I think we
began to share knowledge and understanding of what
this this library was supposed to do, which
I think is super invaluable.
As far as the other features go, we
talked about the reconciliation and what the semantics
are there.
I think what's good is documenting
the knowledge and understanding we have of how
that works now is really important, but also
it provides a framework for extension. Like, no
other developers can come in and go,
maybe we don't want to error when this
fast forward is impossible, and then they can
drop in new best of functionality. They have
new stackies, which helps them build a new
feature fails, new GERK, and and then expand
that library. I I love this as a
framework not for just document and testing, but
just
allowing people to expand the functionality as well.
And then we talk about something that is
really, really undefined at the moment, which is,
well, how do we expose us as a
pops up system for people to then build
their own tooling on top of this with
whatever integrations you want.
I think this document is really cool for
doing that.
And then we started to map that directly
almost from feature rules and examples right into
a get good.
But I will get some test cases put
up and and push us to the repository.
But then we have a full thing from
the stack is to
human documentation
to computer documentation,
which is test.
I really like that. Now
is this something that you think we can
come back and carry on in the future
when I've done a little bit of homework.
I've hooked up a few of these components.
Is that something you would like to do?
Yeah. Sure. I mean, I'm not gonna be
able to help you with the rest particularly.
Well, maybe I could send you some rest
at the same time as well. So Yeah.
But generally, I wouldn't
once you've written out the scenarios
before you put them in version control, we
tend not to keep the example maps around
because they tend to lose meaning quite quickly
because of the lack of details. Right now,
they mean a lot to you and me
and maybe the people watching.
But if we come back to them later,
we might not remember what any of it
means.
So that's visual representation's not too important then?
Like, I mean, what I'm thinking for is,
like, the more feature fails we put together
is good if you want to understand an
individual feature.
Is there not
a way to understand the system as a
whole? Just, like, say you were onboard a
new developer, like, just to get them that
really 10,000 feet overview.
Maybe. Maybe that'd be useful to generate
this if people are really familiar with this
kind of visualization, it'd be interesting to generate
it from feature files, and I wonder if
anyone's doing that. Yeah. But there's less
there's less detail in this than there will
be in the Gherkin
because
Yeah.
Because it's up to it's just like, remember
to write an example about this.
So,
normally
I mean, if it's stickies on a wall,
you know how that goes. That that doesn't
stay too long. They fall off.
Oh, yeah. Definitely.
I can always take a photo of it
and upload it to Confluence. Right? That's what
all professional teams do. Yeah.
That'll work.
Well, I think what I'll do is and
they showed us, I will include the the
example mapping for anyone who's watching,
you know, in the in the future and
and just wants to see what
what I look like. Although, I guess, the
videos are too, but still, you know, I'll
leave it up online, but I'll try not
to refer to it too much on my
own and use the feature files. And I'll
definitely adjust the Googling to see if anyone
has
wrote any tooling to generate maps from feature
files. I think that would be pretty sweet
actually.
Yeah.
Alright. Yeah. I know there is there
are some online example mapping tools.
Wait. We're not using a specific one because
we wanted to just make it simple, but
yeah. Maybe some of them work in reverse.
And, yeah, let's follow-up. Be good.
Alright. Well,
thank you again for donating even more of
your time and teaching me all of your
your magic. It's been very useful. What I'll
do is I will try and
well, I definitely got all the feature fails
written for what we've example mapped. I'll start
to hook that up to Cucumber Rust, which
is a library.
Hopefully, get the features working. And then what
we'll do is I'll chase up with you
in maybe a week, two weeks time. We'll
try and get something else scheduled. I don't
know if it'll be December or if it'll
be be heading next year. We can work
that out later. But we'll try and follow-up
and show people how far along we're getting
with this and hopefully provide more
or at least get more knowledge out of
your brain and share it with people because
I think it's it's fantastic. Great.
You know, I do do this for a
living, so if anyone wants to.
Yeah. Yeah. If your team is looking for
help in this domain, then maybe best just
to, you know, grab you on Twitter, grab
you on any of your socials, whatever.
James says, thank you. No. Thanks for sticking
with us. We hope that was that was
useful. So, Karen, I'll leave it back to
your day. Thank you again, and I'll speak
to you soon. Bye.